hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss
welcome to another episode of the tim
ferriss show where it is usually my job
to sit down with world-class performers
of all different types
to tease out the habits routines
favorite books and so on that you can
apply
and test in your own life or lives as
the case
might be this time we have a slightly
different format and i
am the guest i tested a fan supported
model in 2019 as some of you know
i ended up returning to ads by request
that's a very long story and you can
read more about it at tim.blog
podcast experiment but this is
all to say i still sit down
occasionally with the supporter group in
a private facebook group
for q and a's and fun conversations
things like that just for the hell of it
and we did
a live q a on youtube recently i
answered their questions on my current
morning and exercise routines holotropic
breath work ambition versus
self-compassion
diet and everything from ontological
shock to what is currently bringing me a
lot of joy
how to cultivate not caring what other
people think and much
more with all of that said we cover a
lot of topics
so i hope you enjoy this as much as i
did
this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn
it doesn't matter what your politics are
who you voted for everyone should have
the right to express themselves
freely one way to evade censorship is
with expressvpn which i've been using
since the summer of 2019.
have you ever wondered how a lot of free
to access websites make all their money
well there are a bunch of ways but one
of them is by tracking your searches
video history everything you click on
and then building a profile
on you specifically and selling your
sensitive
data when you use the expressvpn app on
your computer or phone
you anonymize much of your online
presence by hiding your ip address that
makes your activity
more difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers expressvpn encrypts 100 of
your network data to protect you from
eavesdroppers
cybercriminals and the like you can
protect all of your devices
and what i like most is how easy it is
to use it's
easy to download easy to install easy to
set up it just takes
seconds practically that's why
expressvpn is rated
number one by cnet secure your internet
with the vpn i trust for online
protection visit expressvpn.com
tim that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
tim to get three extra months free with
my exclusive link go to expressvpn.com
tim now to learn more
this episode is brought to you by
butcherbox butcherbox makes it easy for
you to get high quality humanely raised
meat that you can trust
they deliver delicious 100 grass-fed
grass-finished beef
free-range organic chicken heritage
breed pork and wild caught seafood
directly to your door for me in the past
few weeks
i've cooked a ton of their salmon as
well as two delicious barbecue rib racks
in the oven
super simple they were the most
delicious pork ribs i've ever prepared
and my freezer is full of butcher box
when you become a member
you're joining a community focused on
doing what's better for all that means
caring about the lives of animals
the livelihoods of farmers treating our
planet with respect and enjoying
better meals together butcherbox
partners with folks small farmers
included who believe in going above and
beyond
when it comes to caring for animals the
environment and sustainability
and none of their meat is ever given
antibiotics or added hormones
so how does it work it's pretty simple
you choose your box and your delivery
frequency they offer five boxes four
curated box options as well as the
popular custom box so you get exactly
what you
and or your family love box options and
delivery frequencies can be customized
to fit your needs you can cancel
at any time with no penalty butcherbox
ships your order frozen for freshness
and packed in an eco-friendly 100
recyclable box
it's easy it's fast it's convenient
i really really enjoy it and best of all
looking at the average cost it works out
to be less than six
dollars per meal bacon for life is back
right now new members can get bacon for
life that's right
when they sign up at butcherbox.com
tim that's one pack of free bacon in
every box for the life of your
subscription when you go to
butcherbox.com
tim at this altitude i can run flat out
for a half mile before my hands start
shaking
can i ask you a personal question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton
how's everybody doing thanks for joining
i'm wearing a c4
shirt for people who might be interested
you can check out c4 foundation
and we're going to do a q a as promised
and the q a will alternate from live
stream
which means the chat
box where everyone is chatting at the
moment you'll be able to submit
questions and why don't we
start with perhaps a few of the
questions
that were pre-submitted so i have a list
of questions that were submitted
and i will do my best to take a stab
at those questions and we'll just go
back and forth
until i run out of time that's about it
so
let's jump into it we see people from
all over the world here
from many different countries scotland
from the netherlands any other people
here from
outside the us
cmdx i wish i knew what that was i don't
know what that is
so perhaps somebody can tell me devin
england montana
vancouver island london canada
socal berlin
montreal great germany ireland
all over so let us just jump into this
q a and i'll say this one more time that
we have questions that were submitted in
advance we also have
live chat and i'll alternate going back
and forth between the two
hopefully we'll have some fun and i'll
do my best
not to provide completely idiotic
answers
i can't give any guarantees on the
questions though although i think most
of these questions are quite strong so
let's just
go to a couple of softball pitches
and then i will jump into the live
stream
number one this is from sarah
s-e-r-a hey tim what's a 2021 updated
version of your morning routine
it is actually quite consistent i think
with
past morning routine the basics are 20
minutes of meditation
first thing in the morning that's
generally going to be some form
of transcendental meditation then
brushing teeth doing the basics of
self-care
and getting downstairs to have poo air
tea usually
peak p-i-q-u-e puair tea
and i'll alternate black and green or
coffee of some type
and as long-term listeners will know i
am
a huge fan of both four sigmatic
mushroom coffee and layered superfood
creamer i had both
this morning in fact from that point on
it really depends on the day so i
organize my week in a thematic
approach meaning rather than taking the
five
types of activities that i need or want
to cover
each week and spreading them throughout
each day i tend to have a day dedicated
to different types of work
so tuesday will involve lots and lots
of phone calls or at least that's when
i'll batch my phone calls with my team
and with other people so very frequently
i will not do any type of journaling on
that day but start walking
and talking so i'll get a lot of my sun
exposure on tuesdays
and so on and so forth so it really
depends on the day
there could be writing following the
caffeination
there could be exercise so twice a week
i'll get into this
next i do some form of acrobatic or
inversion training in the form of
typically acro yoga
and that leads to the next question from
mark chavez what is your current
exercise
routine and what cool exercise equipment
or gadgets are you using
so my weekly routine right now was
really i suppose
first forged in
quarantine so during quarantine began
doing acroyoga twice a week via zoom
with someone named jason niemer as the
instructor
and practicing with my girlfriend
provided us both with
physical contact additional physical
contact and play
several hours of additional contact and
play per week
but also gave us a fantastic way to
move because there are forms of exercise
that really don't entail
a lot of movement through space acro
yoga happens to include all the elements
both acrobatic and therapeutic so we
would do
say 45 to 60 minutes of inversion
practice which would include forearm
stance handstands and so on and there
are many different training tools to use
for that
then do what is known as l-basing where
i'm on my back
holding my girlfriend in the air with my
feet and hands and we have different
roles and responsibilities
in that dynamic and then doing some
version of
thai massage often with traction
towards the end of that workout it's the
combination of the sort of sympathetic
activation and parasympathetic
off-ramp that i think leads to a
great sense of well-being physically and
emotionally for the rest of the day
so twice a week let's just call it
tuesday thursdays
i would have acro in the morning that
would be right after the puertier coffee
then twice a week currently this is
postcovid
climbing so i do bouldering and also top
roping i haven't done my lead climbing
cert yet so i'm not lead climbing and
have really been enjoying
doing that and the two combine very well
acro
is really very much cushioning based
so you're going to be pushing away or
stabilizing with a pushing movement of
some type with both your arms and your
legs of course in rock climbing
you do have pushing in the legs but it
is largely pulling
otherwise and so i find that that tends
to
balance out the say antagonistic muscle
groups
so that you don't develop if you
approach it in a moderate way which i am
you don't develop
the repetitive stress pain and injuries
that have plagued me
for most of my life by the virtue of
overdoing things or i should say the
vice of overdoing things so even though
my body might be able to handle climbing
three or four times a week
i am limiting myself to twice a week and
that has been fantastic it has meant
that despite the fact i had complete
shoulder reconstruction on my left
shoulder in the early 2000s
and elbow surgery on my right elbow more
recently
i have been able to train without
extended pain
of course little nicks and bruises and
so on so we have climbing twice a week
we have acro twice a week
and then we have weight training
typically of some type
one to two times per week this is
nothing fancy it's something along the
lines of say saying occam's protocol
in the four hour body or kettlebell
swings
it's very basic it's generally going to
be 20 to 40 minutes
and it is for the purpose of
injury prevention first and foremost not
performance enhancement and
last but not least walking i walk a fair
amount on tuesdays during calls i would
say i walk
for three to five hours minimum and
do my best certainly when i have access
to trails and so on
to walk for a minimum of an hour per day
and i find
that walking is not just physically
therapeutic but psycho-emotionally
incredibly
therapeutic so that is what the exercise
routine looks like
so we checked off two of those let's try
a few questions
from the live stream so we'll look at a
couple of questions from the live stream
here edgar inoue i think
is how we pronounce that question what
is your process to determine if you're
going the right direction sometimes we
might get lost in trying to accomplish
things instead of thinking
about what is worth working for really
this is an
energetic canary in the coal mine for me
in the sense that if you
find yourself low energy which
is very often accompanied by depressive
or pessimistic thoughts
then i will do a number of things
including
80 20 analysis and some form of
dreamlining is outlined
in the four hour workweek but i will
very frequently
take the 80 20 analysis and apply it in
two
columns and those are the
say 20 of people and activities that are
producing
80 or more of my peak positive emotional
states and then
on the other side peak negative
emotional
states or negative ads and
negative subtractions and i will look at
that but
but really it's just using a
simple rubric like how quickly do you
fall asleep
and how do you feel when you first wake
up when you first wake up
is there a feeling of dread of oh [ __ ] i
have to slog through another day of not
really knowing where i'm going
or is it a different feeling so for me
as jody foster
once said i believe could be
misattribution but
in the end winning is sleeping well
something along those lines
so it's really how do you feel right
before you go to bed or when you go to
bed and how do you feel
right when you wake up and if something
is off i believe you know it it doesn't
need to be put into a spreadsheet and
analyzed
and then the question is figuring out
where to focus
and to that point i am
actually going to hop to another
question
here in front of me which might be
related on some level this is a question
from steve
schwab and this might seem like a hard
left turn but i don't think it is
so steve schwab's question is i have
constant thoughts about the meaning
or meaninglessness of life and
discomfort with death therefore i
distract myself with work do you have
any recommendations on managing these
thoughts
and i wanted to bring this up because
let's say
you are having the experience of a
malaise
you are having trouble falling asleep or
you have
a certain level of anxiety about the
unknown
or you wake up and feel that you are
without direction
i think those feelings are often
combined
with these difficulties or challenges
that steve is outlining
so do i have any recommendations on
managing these thoughts
i'm not going to start with an answer to
that i'll start by saying
that for the last several months i have
had constant thoughts about the
meaninglessness
of life and quite a bit of discomfort or
angst
around death so what am i doing so in
this case i'm not going to provide an
answer
necessarily because i also think that's
a very personal thing but i'll tell you
how
i am looking to reboot the system and
hopefully navigate that number one is
i'm going to re-read victor frankel's
book man's search for meaning which i've
been meaning to reread for a very long
time
i also have a book a friend recommended
called smile
at fear i can't vouch for it yet because
i haven't read it the author i'm going
to butcher this name
chagyam trungpa that's
c-h-o-g-y-a-m-t-r-u-n-g-p-a but smile at
fear
the title should find you the book and
i'm also
going to read biographies
of people who found meaning and really i
don't know how much of it is finding
meaning versus
choosing meaning and i don't think there
is
any inherent single objective
meaning of life that should guide your
steps
and decisions it seems to me that it is
a personal
decision of sorts perhaps that is with a
vocation perhaps you feel called
something perhaps you pursue something
but i'm looking for models of people who
have done that
and so i think biographies will also
hold
an important position in my trying to
navigate
this particular period in my life
so there you have my answer in a way
to both of those alright so let me
scroll down see what other questions we
have in the live stream
andrew robinson if you were asked to
give a commencement speech what would be
the core message the core message would
be you are the average of the five
people you spend the most time with
so pick them very carefully and prune
very carefully
over time because some friends are
for a night some for a season and some
for life
and all are welcome there is a place and
a time and there are certainly many
benefits
and enjoyments to be had for all
but those categories can change and not
everyone is forever
all right two additional questions
in the stream this is from johnny miller
are any of the maps or johns hopkins
studies that you're aware of looking at
the therapeutic effect of holotropic
breath work what do you view as the
potential and opportunities for breath
work
so for those who are not familiar
maps.org is a non-profit
that is the driving force behind the
phase
three studies for mdma-assisted
psychotherapy for
ptsd and this very often involves
veterans victims of sexual abuse etc
mdma has been shown to have tremendous
promise there was a huge
cover story that is the cover of the new
york times
print edition discussing uh
maps and rick doblin's work and so on in
this area
and johns hopkins at least in this
particular reference
is looking at psilocybin which is the
psychoactive or one of the psychoactive
compounds found in philosophy mushrooms
or magic mushrooms
for treating things like nicotine
addiction
end of life existential distress and
cancer patients etc
so i'm not aware of any studies
being sponsored by maps or being
conducted at johns hopkins
that incorporate holotropic breath work
specifically but i think there is
tremendous
certainly and this is not a discovery of
mine or
anything novel from me there are i
believe
very interesting applications of breath
work
both to therapy and somatic awareness
somatic release
that would be true in something like
hacomi therapy h-a-k-o-m-i which i think
is a fantastic adjunct to any type of
psychedelic assisted therapy it can also
be used
and certainly this is true in holotropic
breath work
which is so named because the
tropic portion refers to turning towards
hollow wholeness turning towards
wholeness right so you
would have heliotropic flowers for
instance that turn towards the sun
holotropic would be turning towards
wholeness and it was created
much like the drumming of michael harner
this would be a separate example
holotropic breath work was created by
stan groff who was is a psychiatrist or
psychotherapist originally from the
czech republic
who was looking for an alternative
to psychedelic compounds after they were
legalized
during the nixon administration and you
can use
intense breath work such as holotropic
breath work to experience
non-ordinary states of consciousness
what some might call altered states of
consciousness
without drugs and there is value in this
certainly and my recommendation to
anyone who
approaches me and asks about
psychedelics
is often unless it's contraindicated for
them and there are some
contraindications
that they experience something like
holotropic breath work first because
a it's legal and b it does not involve
any drugs which can provoke a lot of
anxiety in many people
so i view that as a precursor or a
prerequisite almost
to engaging in any type of psychedelic
therapy but i'm not aware of any studies
i do believe
that jamie wheel w-h-e-a-l
is involved or may be involved in some
studies related to holotropic breath
work
and that is not the only breath work
that can be used
for all of the purposes that i have been
describing there are many others
all right let's jump to another question
in the stream and thanks for joining
everybody this is fun i enjoy this
just see a note from
ganchin careful with pseudo-shamans
though yes be careful with
pseudo-shamans
and rent-a-shamans or yogawasca
practitioners
if anyone calls themselves a shaman in
fact i would say
generally that is a red flag and you
should probably steer clear of them
because the well-trained
indigenous practitioners or those who
have spent decades
working in specific lineages in my
experience without exception do not call
themselves shamans
they have a particular term usually
pulled from one of the native languages
like quechua or
spanish or fill in the blank to describe
what they do
so if someone runs up to you with a
voucher for discounted
shamanic experiences run the other
direction
question from reese zanino in a recent
podcast you talked about joint pain have
you tried fish oil moxa sticks or
acupuncture what has been the most
effective tool for you
i've tried all these things moxie i
found interesting moxa
or moxibustion moxa sticks using radiant
heat at the
joint above the skin so you're taking a
burning stick and holding it near the
skin
definitely not on the skin what i have
found most helpful
for certain types of joint issues like
elbow pain for instance from climbing
is a modulating volume
so there is a dose
that will make the exercise of poison
right as paracelsus would say
so if you exercise too much you are
going to suffer the consequences and so
one is really just finding a cadence of
exercise that works
where you can still adapt and get
stronger without
causing chronic tendinosis etc that's
number one number two
is working the muscles that act in
opposition so if you're climbing and
doing a lot of pulling for instance
you're going to be working the flexors
of the forearm tremendously
so you'd want to do some complementary
exercises with the
extensors and you can use any number of
devices for that you could use
also a bucket of rice there are many
exercises that rock climbers use
involving a large bucket of rice
which i found helpful voodoo floss
created by my friend kelly starrett
i found tremendously helpful also to use
after climbing for the arms specifically
although it can be used for many
different parts of the body so people
can look up voodoo floss
i'm sure on youtube to find videos of
kelly demonstrating
how this can be used and otherwise
contrast therapy hot cold
so i have a hot tub i also have a sauna
you could
certainly just use a hot bath if you're
fortunate enough to have
two baths you could have one hot and
then one full of ice and
at an extremely cold temperature so i
have a
chest freezer that i have converted into
a cold plunge be sure to unplug
the freezer so you don't electrocute
yourself and
based on some recommendations from
kingsbury modified
meaning really just caulking to
fully waterproof the freezer to make it
a cold plunge so i will go
hot cold hot cold hot cold usually let's
just call it
three minutes in each and this is well
documented for
recovery effects and then nutrition
so those are a few of the things a few
of the levers
that i have pulled most recently at
least to address
or rather prevent elbow pain and this
also applies to
my shoulder and last but not least
i would say technique before volume so
in the case of rock climbing i do
foresee a point where i will be able to
train
three or four or more times per week
right now my
technique is so inefficient and
my joints or more accurately my tendons
and ligaments
have not strengthened at the same pace
as my musculature so i'm being very very
cautious
but there will be a point and i hope to
climb for many decades
where i'll be able to add volume to that
all right so i get this question a lot
do you know of any psychedelic retreats
that i can recommend i can't do that of
course because
as much as i wish i could immediately
whatever i recommend would suffer as one
listener called it the hug of death
and they would get more applications
than they could accept they would
attempt to increase capacity
and then quality and customer service
would go through the floor and it would
be a complete disaster for everyone
involved so frank chen
who or what has consistently brought you
joy in the past six months one year
three years five years
well i would say like we're talking who
you know my girlfriend's the first
who comes to mind and then of course we
have molly pup
my companion and my second girlfriend
and then that's one and the same it's a
joke folks i'm saying molly is my other
girlfriend
and then best friends etc so that's kind
of self-evident i suppose but
the what has consistently brought me joy
in the past six months
one year consistent joy period
in the last year during covid i have
found to be tremendously challenging but
i would say two things come to mind and
that is extended time
in nature where i do not hear the noise
of mankind and i say that right now
because i'm sitting in a house where
we have construction on almost every
side and it is driving me
cuckoo bananas extended time in nature
and that involves also
rocking so taking a weighted backpack i
use goruck
for training purposes and just going for
long hikes
in old growth forests if at all possible
of course nature anywhere i think is
very medicinal
but tall trees big canopy is
particularly
calming for my system the japanese might
call it tree bathing
and then also learning more about the
plants and animals so that you
can click the dial a few notches on the
resolution of what you
see because of course until you have
labels for things until you have names
for things
it is very difficult to distinguish them
from the background
of say your visual experience that's why
children need to learn infants and
toddlers and so on
labels so that they can distinguish
between chair
table wall and so on so that they aren't
just patterns
of light and color and shadow that are
somehow
i suppose indistinguishable and to do
that you need
you need names you need labels so i've
taken walks with field biologists
i have taken walks with biologists of
several different types just
through common public trails to learn to
be able to
identify different trees that's where i
started because
at least on the east coast where i first
did this
the biologist said to me look we could
try to learn flowers
and there are going to be hundreds of
different wildflowers and you're going
to have
tremendous trouble separating one from
the next
and it could be very frustrating or i
could teach you eight trees and you'll
be able to identify
90 of the trees that you see here and i
found that to be good advice so those
those are two
things time and nature often
moving not just sitting still but that's
personal preference
and then learning the plants and animals
the flora and fauna of that given
area daniel viba
i'm not sure if that's how you pronounce
it that's how i would read it
any plans for different projects over
the next two to three years
i think there is a decent chance that i
will finally
write or rather finish because i'm
actually pretty far through it
the screenplay for the four hour work
week which would be
kind of a best in show zoolander
comedy of sorts but it would all be
based on true events
and there would be a lot of philosophy
and a lot of i think
practical takeaways along the lines of
something like
fight club so that's kind of my
pet project in the back of my mind that
i have not yet finished and i really
should finish so
i envision that probably being a major
project for me or at least a project
i don't want to make it bigger than it
needs to be project for me in the next
two to three years
i would like to do more in the visual
medium
all right there's a recommendation from
josh or joshua armstrong also check out
victor frankl's yes to life it's a
compilation of lectures he gave before
publishing man's search for meaning
and i found it to be more actionable as
direct advice that is
great advice joshua so thank you
i will check that out because i am
all for actionable at the moment
although the conceptual stuff
ultimately can soak in and
help with your view of the world that
then informs other decisions but
i will check out that collection of i
guess
transcribed lectures basically there's a
question here
any research on the effects just to
revisit this because it's come up
from a few people any research on the
effects of psychedelics combined with
breath work
increased synergistic effect i
suspect that it depends on the compound
but absolutely
it is very common that breath work
administered to people
on psychedelics and there are different
versions of this one is referred to as
power breathing
has a multiplicative effect on the dose
so for instance if we consider a normal
hit
of lsd to be 100 micrograms if you were
to give someone 50 micrograms and then
have them
do the equivalent of wim hof or
holotropic breath work
from say after the point of
administration
minutes 30 to 60. my expectation would
be that
many people would subjectively
feel it as if it were between 100
micrograms and 200 micrograms
so that is worth being aware of let's
look at some
other questions and of course i'm not
recommending that anyone use
any illegal compounds so i'm not a
doctor i don't play one on the internet
nor am i your lawyer
so everything we're discussing here is
for
informational purposes only
okay it's a question from debbie
debbie wheel or vile i'm 69 married and
have six grandchildren definitely not in
your target demographic but still a big
fan thank you debbie i appreciate that
i don't think i have a target demo so
maybe that makes everyone my target demo
so i appreciate you
being a fan question why are you still
hesitating about having children
i'm not hesitating about having kids
actually i hesitated for a long time
because a
i wasn't convinced that i would be a
good father
and i needed to have some conviction
around that before
even contemplating having kids because i
think it's it is inherently a selfish
choice or self-interested choice you're
having kids because you want to have
kids
as far as we know they are not choosing
to
have you as a parent so i really wanted
to do
a lot of self-work and
go through quite a lot of therapy many
different types of therapy for childhood
trauma etc before
even considering that as an option it
just it seemed like the only ethical way
to approach it
and secondly some of my hesitation has
been around my genetic predisposition
and it is a genetic predisposition i've
seen this
in my family certainly to depressive
episodes
and whether or not i want to pass along
genetic code that could predispose
someone who didn't ask for it to
experience
depressive episodes on a regular basis
but at this point
for many reasons i am in the process
of seeing fertility docs and going
through the pre-flight
checklist so to speak to ensure that all
systems are go and then
i think we're off to the races so tbd on
outcomes but that is the current plan so
i am
i'm no longer hesitating in my mind
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis you would
have missed out on fifty percent
five zero percent of your returns don't
miss out on the best days in the market
stay invested in a long-term automated
investment portfolio wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes
it takes about three minutes to sign up
and then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your risk appetite and manage
it for you at an incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay on your investment
gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into
savings or an investment account they've
really thought of a ton they've checked
a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today and
you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free
for life that's wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today
at wealthfront.com tim
recommendation from roland's jiggeroffs
watch kumari about how to become a fake
shaman this is actually excellent advice
so anyone who is listening to this
i would strongly suggest that you watch
a documentary called kumare i don't want
to ruin it so just watch the trailer
k-u-m-a-r-e and if you want to train
yourself to look on the bright side if
you want to have a degree of optimism
while simultaneously
learning to defend yourself more
effectively against
charlatans this is a great documentary
it is a real
fun watch and it is also one hell of a
nail biter i'll leave it at that
bogdan bulgarian if that is you know
bogdan the bulgarian
what a great name so bogdan i may
abridge your question a little bit
but i think it's a good one and it's one
that i get a fair amount or i've seen a
fair amount
here it is you've mentioned that you
believe your hard charging beat yourself
up attitude actually held you back
rather than helped
you get ahead can you explain more about
why you think that's the case
it seems a lot of successful people
spend their 20s and 30s grinding super
hard to get to where they are
and it's only once they've achieved
success they take the point of view
i shouldn't have been so hard on myself
do you think that you would have
overcome all the obstacles you had if
you had been more self-compassionate
even in your 20s and 30s
so this is a great question and on one
level it's impossible to answer so i
can't
run a monte carlo simulation on my life
and say
if i had behaved in these different ways
reviewed myself in these other ways
that the outcomes would have been the
same or i would have reached the same
degree of financial success
but i do think that the word successful
is worth underlining here so
and that is why i said financial success
and i modified it in that way
here's what i can say is that a lot of
people
who compulsively
focus on professional achievement
have demons whipping them in their back
and
that there are exceptions certainly
but many of the people who achieve
outsized financial success
success in any measurable way that can
be socially reinforced
and appreciated and lauded on magazine
covers and so on
have super powers and equally
super deficits and
that many of them
after making millions of dollars or
billions of dollars
remain quite tortured and
unhappy so i just want to say that as a
preface
that word successful is very dangerous
so i would i would encourage
everybody when you use that word
successful
at the very least to throw a modifier in
front of it
like financially successful or even
better financially independent or post
economic or whatever
the concept is that you're seeking to
describe to this point
i can't speak for my experience because
i've only had
the life that i've had but there are
also counter examples
so whenever someone says i
can't do or i couldn't have done x
because i
am y or i had to do x
or i have to do x because i am y
one of the first questions that i always
have or that comes to mind
is are there any counter examples and
i could say for instance and the
phrasing
will change but people are successful
because financially successful because
they have a beat yourself up attitude in
their 20s and 30s
that leads them to grind super hard
question are there counter examples and
there are i actually have quite a few
friends
who did not self-flagellate to my
knowledge
and were not malicious to themselves
did not constantly focus on
their flaws who have had
outsized financial success so is it
necessary no i don't think so is it
common
yes so then the question is should you
risk it if you're in your 20s and 30s
should you risk being self-compassionate
and
what i would say is i see very little
downside
so if you are someone who is even asking
this question
you are probably not being
self-compassionate if that makes any
sense so you already have some edge
of beat yourself up attitude if you're
even asking this question
and if i look at what i have achieved
just by adding a little bit of softness
a little bit of
slowness a little bit of spaciousness to
my life through say meditation
20 minutes in the morning that's it
forget about self-compassion that just
gets
too squishy for a lot of hard driving
kind of mckinsey i banker
aspiring folks who just you know want to
conquer the world so let's not use
self-compassion but
what about meditating 20 minutes in the
morning this will help you to become
more
self-aware let's start there forget
about compassion
if you have the ability to pause
even for a few seconds before
reflexively responding
say in anger or in anything if you have
the ability to be more self-aware so
that you can
regulate more effectively will that make
you more effective or will that make you
less effective i think it will make you
more effective
these things will naturally lead i think
to some degree of
of self-compassion so if we deconstruct
it that way
i would have to say a i have yet to find
someone who has cultivated
any of these behaviors who has said i've
lost my edge
i lost my drive completely i can't
achieve anything anymore and i really
regret it i've never met anyone who has
said that
this is also true for people in their
20s and 30s
the second thing i would say is that
when you take the edge off a little bit
because this is also a concern in
therapy people don't want to go to
therapy because they're afraid they'll
lose their edge
this is very true for people like
comedians or entertainers oftentimes
or they don't want to meditate they
don't want to journal because they might
lose their edge whatever that is
and in my experience you don't lose your
edge
you become more aware
of the psychological clothing you put on
the stories that you tell yourself etc
that
produce that edge if that makes any
sense right so you become aware of the
recipe that you use for the edge
and you could view that like a
the analogy that i've used with with one
person
is it's like a jacket
that you take off and you put in your
closet
you still have that jacket if you need
that edge you know where to find it and
you can put it back on
and you can get out and you know you can
scorch the earth or you can
conquer the world whatever it it happens
to be if somebody for instance like i
found
a stalker came out of the woodwork and
really bothered me
and there was a risk that they were
going to be a threat to someone in my
family
so i went into my wardrobe and i took
out my killer cloak and i put it on
and i like quadrupled my edge and i was
able
to solve the problem uh
needless to say and then i can take off
that cloak and put it back
in my wardrobe and not wear it 24 7.
there's a time and a place for it
but it's like a smoking jacket that's
the analogy i used with this
with this friend i said like smoking
jackets cool great but
you wear it when you're smoking in a
lounge it's a very specific use case you
don't [ __ ] wear it to starbucks
you don't walk around all day in your
office wearing a smoking jacket you'd be
a weirdo and it's just not
necessary so that's a very very long
answer to your question but
hopefully that is helpful in some
capacity
and here's the other thing it's not all
or nothing it's like when a female
friends of mine say if i lift weights
i'll get really
bulky won't i and i say that's not going
to happen overnight you're not just
going to turn into some
show pony with like quadzillas
in 48 hours so train
do some resistance training and it's
going to be incremental
and if you don't like it stop you know
you're not going to become
a buddhist master monk overnight if you
start meditating or considering
some of these topics by reading books
like radical acceptance
or awareness by anthony demelo for
instance
there you are bogdan hopefully that is
helpful
okay question from john and then we're
going to jump back
into the live stream
john says you've covered and
experimented with a number of different
eating approaches time restricted eating
fasting 30 grams of protein in the
morning slow carb keto et cetera what's
your current eating plan or schedule
look like i'm back to slow carb i've
tried so many things
and this low carb diet generally
speaking is going to be my preferred
method of eating
and i'm not doing much time restricted
eating i think that there
there are i am sure benefits i am sure
because they're documented there are
benefits to time-restricted eating
but right now i'm trying to add muscle
mass
and strength with a lot of the training
that i'm doing so i am
not using time-restricted eating and
there are people who will say you can
use
time-restricted eating or intermittent
fasting to enhance
anabolism i just find it easier to
follow a normal
more or less three meal per day slow
carb diet
in pursuing that and then from a fasting
perspective i still try to do
and aim to do say a three-day fast
meaning a 72-hour
water fast once per month and then at
least
a single one week fast
per year that is my current regimen
and if you have not fasted before please
do so
under medical supervision speak to your
general practitioner beforehand please
because not everyone tolerates
fasting terribly well and you listen to
my podcasts
with dr dominic de agostino
d apostrophe a-g-o-s-t-i-n-o
for all the detail in the world you
could possibly want on fasting he is
one of the country's top experts all
right that is
john and let's jump into the live
questions here
all right here's a question from daniel
any particular thinkers or writers you
found very helpful regarding child
rearing and preparation for fatherhood
uh obviously the general work with
acceptance self-love etc but on rear and
children
so daniel honestly i have not begun
to read those books because once i let
that genie out of the bottle i'm gonna
read a hundred of them
my general feeling is spending time
with my friends who i consider to be
excellent parents
and excellent partners and i do look for
them to check both boxes
is the best preparation that i can do
in addition to all the self-work that
you mentioned i think that if
you try to make yourself the most
compassionate aware person possible
obviously with boundaries i think i will
be a strict parent on a lot of
levels and you trust your biology
we have been giving birth and raising
children successfully for a very very
long time well before
what to expect when you're expecting
came out even though i hear that's a
very good book
so i'm not overly
anxious or insecure about
parenting because i do think that a lot
of switches will be flipped
as soon as is is really we get into the
process of getting pregnant giving birth
and so on but
i'll keep you posted recommendation
to daniel might not be exactly what
you're looking for this is from
another commenter but the book by gabor
mate
scattered minds touches a lot of
important topics on
importance of early development
all right let's jump back to the
questions i have here in front of me
here's one from
max max asks do you have any advice for
dealing with ontological
shock like that of the realization of
your childhood abuse
a sudden and dramatic need to rewrite
the existing narratives of your life and
identity i'm
struggling with this so thanks for the
question max
i want to take a close look at this
phrase ontological shock i first heard
this
phrase from roland griffiths at
johns hopkins with reference to what
some people
some patients can experience after their
first
mystical experience on higher doses of
something like
psilocybin so what is ontology ontology
now
the branch of metaphysics dealing with
the nature of being
two a set of concepts and categories in
a subject area domain that shows their
properties and relations
between them it's really sort of a
nature of being a nature of knowing this
is how i think about this
the ontological shock that someone can
experience in a psychedelic
session would include being unable
to reconcile new
experiences of reality or
new experiences of non-ordinary states
of consciousness
that seem hyper real how do you take
this experience and then reconcile it
with
your normal ordinary way of being in the
world
turns out that it can be extremely
difficult and
very jarring for people it can take in
some instances
weeks or months or years to readjust if
you don't have
help this is not something that happens
all the time but it is something
that happens with some frequency then
you have
we could call it ontological shock say
of the realization
or the surfacing of memories related to
childhood abuse or any type of abuse or
trauma for that matter
i have found a number of tools very
helpful for this
i do find ifs internal family systems to
be very helpful
created by dick schwartz i did a podcast
episode with
dick schwartz where we actually did a
live
session of ifs to really
demonstrate and showcase the
characteristics of that method
and there are ifs therapists around the
world
so i would suggest taking a look at that
podcast to see if it's something that
might be of interest
the next that comes to mind and this
applies in many arenas
is the work by byron katie
and it's really a series of questions
form of self-inquiry that allows you to
interrogate your thoughts or examine and
cross-examine
your thoughts or beliefs and beliefs
being thoughts we take is true so the
work by byron katie you can find online
and many worksheets and so on can be
found for free
on her website and the
the last book i'll mention quickly here
actually there are two one i already
mentioned radical acceptance by tara
brock b-r-a-c-h
she's also been a guest on the podcast
because almost all of my guests
on the podcast have some
connection to my life meaning i invite
them on the podcast
because of a personal curiosity or a
personal
challenge or personal goal so tara brock
has been on my podcast that could serve
as a teaser
if you want to consider radical
acceptance which
is a fantastic fantastic book the last
book that i'll mention in this
particular answer
is one by bruce tift t-i-f-t
the book is already free and the
titles were saying twice already free
subtitle buddhism meets psychotherapy on
the path
to liberation and i found this book
to be a kin after reading say the first
50 to 75 pages to taking off
a hundred pound backpack you didn't even
realize you'd been carrying
and i think that in combination with
radical acceptance really offers
a synergistic one-two punch that could
help a lot with
many different types of ontological
shock so i will leave it at that
and i wish you good luck it's a
difficult experience
and that doesn't mean it is a valueless
experience
and sometimes we experience
breakdowns so that we can experience
breakthroughs i know that sounds very
cliched but certainly i have come to
believe that
in my own personal experience all right
i'm looking at
some additional questions now here
in the live stream chloe carroll have
you finished reading
overstory yet yes i finished reading the
overstory
which is for those who don't know is a
pulitzer prize winning
novel it is incredibly good it is
incredibly long
you need to give it time to tie the
different threads together
i thought it was a beautiful book it has
certainly increased my interest
in trees botany plants which one might
expect
i recommend it to everyone it contains
a lot of beauty and a lot of brutality
and for anyone who's read it that'll
make sense and
i think there's a tendency to shield
ourselves
from brutality which makes a lot of
sense
in part because it's easy to succumb to
what someone on my team called doom
scrolling particularly
during covid when every news headline
every article seems optimized to cause a
panic response or a
rage response and that is i think
a form of unfiltered unselected
brutality that is to be avoided right
that would be
stress in the form of distress then you
have stress
in the form of the opposite which is
eustress eu
like like euphoria so positive stress
weight lifting would be an example of
this the rock climbing that i'm doing
would be an example of this these are
stressors
or sunlight leading to a suntan that you
want
stressors that produce an adaptation and
i think
selecting
painful truths or certain types of
brutality
and becoming familiar with them
particularly if
there is the combination with beauty as
you would find
in the overstory it allows you to
inoculate yourself
a bit and what i mean by that is
if you constantly shield yourself from
the difficult
from what you perceive to be the
negative when you are
for factors well outside of your control
forced to encounter the negative the
difficult the destructive
you may find that you are more fragile
you may find that you are increasingly
having trouble withstanding
the the onslaught if you have not
trained yourself in some fashion with
the combination
which you can find of beauty and
brutality and perhaps that's a strange
way to put it but i do believe there's
something to that
ricky asked me are you sure you're not
drunk i'm 100 sure i'm not drunk i also
recorded a very long very fun podcast
just a few hours ago so i've i've
already been talking for
say three hours today so i think there's
something to that everyone who's
listening should try
talking for six hours and then uh seeing
how their speech evolves or devolves
over the day
somebody asked when this ends not sure i
mean we've gone for
an hour i'll probably go for a little
bit longer
especially since apparently my brain
function is faltering
but i will probably go for another
20 to 30 minutes eh let's call it 15 to
30 minutes
there's a question what am i laughing at
the most these days
someone also asked about evening
routines and
in the evening very often my catch up
time with my girlfriend
is dinners we do have date nights
twice a week and i think it's very
important to block those out
otherwise life will just crowd out that
time with people you care about
so we have date nights twice a week one
is tonight so i will be certainly not
staying on for
hours in that case and then we have hot
tub
or sauna which is just a great way to
physically
let go and then we will very often watch
a short tv show of some type
right now that's shit's creek that's
s-c-h-i-t-t
apostrophe s creek which is
absolutely hilarious the episodes are
extremely short
we are about i want to say three
quarters of the way through season two
and it's outstanding it is really
well done and the characters are
all uniquely hilarious and
it's easy it's very easy so i would say
that
is one example of where i am laughing
the most
these days here's a question from robert
metcalf
when you get into an unproductive
thought or emotional loop are there any
particular practices quotes reminders
that you return to for grounding and
clear thinking
i'll be the first to confess that i get
into unproductive
thought or emotional loops all the
[ __ ] time uh
so if that makes anybody feel any better
this is an
ongoing challenge and so it goes
that's okay particular practices quotes
reminders practice number one would be
morning pages
as described by julia cameron there is a
morning pages
workbook that i use it is literally on
my kitchen table
right now and you can learn all about
that
just by searching my name tim ferriss
and morning pages and i wrote an entire
blog post on how i approached that
so i won't rehash it here but that is
definitely
one of my go-to practices quotes
i have a piece of wood that has a quote
laser etched into it and it's not so
much a quote as a proverb it's a polish
proverb
and it's very simple not my circus not
my monkeys
now why would i use that very often
because my unproductive thought
or emotional loop is triggered by some
[ __ ] that gets foisted upon me
like a hot potato and
i would say in combination with not my
circus not my monkeys
the expression your lack of preparation
does not constitute my emergency
which was said to me once way back in
the day when i was getting started
because i was trying to rush someone to
do something
and it is simply a reminder
that if you allow everyone else's to-do
list to become your to-do list
you will have a life replete of
emergencies
and that just produces a daily
experience
and a life of cortisol which i don't
think any of us want now granted you
need cortisol
if you didn't have it you would die but
you don't want to have
a life that is dominated by stress
hormones so those are a few
and then last but not least
and i know i've mentioned this already
in this episode
and the fact that i will mention it
again should tell you that i view it as
valuable the book awareness by anthony
demello
it is a constant
source of nourishment with incredible
after effects i find myself really to be
at peace for two to three weeks
after reading awareness with
fresh eyes and i always find a new
nuance or a new takeaway from this book
even though i've read it probably
12 times at this point something along
10 to 12 times
i would say minimum i have an entire
shelf in my guest bedroom at home
that is full of copies of awareness to
give to friends who come to visit and
that
is how strongly i feel about the
benefits
comment from justin stewart ted lasso is
a good one too
i polled my followers on twitter
and facebook and so on so a few million
people asking for
an easy feel good series to binge watch
and ted lasso lasso came up repeatedly
it was probably one of the top
three so that is also on
my list and even in this chat there are
many plus ones for ted lasso
matt ridley asks how much time do i set
aside for reading each
week i tend to read before bed as a way
to wind down
and very frequently i would say you know
once or twice a week i will try to
read this is often if i am feeling
anxious for whatever reason or rushed
but without a clear explanation i will
meditate
have my tear coffee then lay down on the
couch with my dog
and read for 30 to 60 minutes so i would
say if you total it all
up i am probably reading for
three to five hours per week if i'm
traveling it will be
significantly higher here how active
are you in lobbying congress to decrease
restrictions on psychedelic research
well there are many challenges
in the arena of psychedelic research
certainly one
is the federal scheduling of
most of these compounds and suffice to
say
i am active on almost every front
related to psychedelic research question
from looks like greek unfortunately i
can't read greek
phonetically so i apologize have you
given serious thoughts to writing
fiction
yes i have and in fact i have been
writing short stories in fiction and
i've been doing that
in the mornings before inputs often on
the weekends
and it has been tremendously
liberating and it is quite similar to
rock climbing in fact and i think part
of the reason i enjoy both
is that you might have an idea of where
you're starting the first few moves
and then you get up on the wall and
unless you've specced out the entire
route
you need to improvise and you begin
to problem solve and play with puzzles
on the way up and i quite enjoy that
which is very different from my
experience of non-fiction
non-fiction is more like for me at least
carpentry
it's a lot of research preparation
laying out the outlines
knowing where you're going having the
data
in front of you this is
much more similar to playing with
building blocks
or finger paints or something like that
not to in any way
denigrate fiction great fiction i find
almost
impossible to comprehend as a craft i
don't know how
someone like the author of little big
for instance
writes the way that he writes i just
don't know how it's done
it really boggles my mind but
i am taking it step by step bird by bird
as one might say which is also one of
my favorite books on the craft of
writing and fiction which is really
also a great book on the craft of living
bird by bird by anne
lamott all right i'm going to go back
and i think i am going to wrap up in a
few minutes because my brain is clearly
lagging with my slurring
and i promise you no drug involved maybe
i need more drugs
all right let me take a look all right
i'm going to read
this question from andrew robinson not
because my answer
is a great answer although i i think it
may be helpful to some people but it's
an important topic
so andrew asks how do you overcome the
fear of being misunderstood
it seems that you have made many
decisions in your personal and
professional life
example given opting out of a more
typical career path after princeton
extreme experimentation quitting startup
investing and most recently sporting
psychedelic research
that might be confusing at first even
for those in your personal life anything
other than fear setting that comes to
mind for
helping you manage how others whether
personal friends or the general public
may perceive your decisions
so this is a topic that we could explore
for an entire episode but i do think
the first principles are important
because you can come up with all sorts
of strategies and tactics but
underlying those are some assumptions or
beliefs
and those are in a sense the first
principles
so for me i suppose there are
a couple of things to consider
that first you should assume you're
almost
always going to be misunderstood or i
should say
if you assume you will always be
misunderstood because
think about how difficult it is to
understand yourself how many people
listening right now can say i understand
myself perfectly
i certainly can't say that i don't even
know what understand would mean in such
a context
but there are misunderstandings left
right and center
every day probably every hour every
minute
as we sit here engaging
in this live q a certainly and
if we then just assume that
understanding
as a concept is sort of hard to wrap our
heads around with a lot
and that even if we could wrap our heads
around it we're going to be constantly
misunderstood
that removes a lot of the pressure to
make yourself understood
if that makes any sense so if the secret
to happiness is low expectations
as i was told by one of my danish
friends when i asked them why
denmark rated as one of the happiest
countries on earth
then perhaps the key to overcoming the
fear of being
misunderstood is just to assume that
everyone misunderstands everyone and
that there is no point
that it is pissing in the wind to try to
prevent
people from misunderstanding you so
that's point number one
point number two is that we
dramatically overestimate how much
people
are thinking about us people
think about themselves most of us spend
the vast majority of our time
in the me me me movie where we are the
lead actor or actress
everyone else is supporting cast and
we are ruminating and perseverating
on all sorts of nonsense we occasionally
stumble upon something important but
mostly
think about trivialities related to our
own lives our own goals our own fears
what other people might be thinking even
though
in truth everyone else is also in their
own
solo act and that
i think can be tremendously freeing when
you assume
that everyone else your family closest
friends etc
are also somewhat compulsively
self-referential and thinking about
themselves most of the time
they're just not thinking about you most
of the time and that can be
instead of being depressing very very
uplifting and reassuring
so you can feel free in a sense
to do what you believe the next right
thing is
because it doesn't really matter they're
not thinking about you
at least it doesn't matter on that level
you can also
focus on communication and expressing
needs and expressing
your motivations without attachment to
the response
that comes and that takes
practice i've been very fortunate to
have felt a lot of support
not necessarily for every decision but i
felt support for
marching to the beat of my own drummer
if that makes
any sense so those are a few
thoughts related to not
overcoming the fear of being
misunderstood but reframing
the fear of being misunderstood and i
hope those
are helpful you could also read
make good art or better yet watch the
commencement speech make good art by
neil gaiman
g-a-i-m-a-n and it doesn't address
this perfectly but it speaks to
vulnerability and i think that
vulnerability
whether it's a fear of vulnerability or
a wish to be more candid with those
around you
that is the connective tissue between
those two recommendations
i think that
is going to be it guys i think i'll take
a quick look
at some of the questions that we have in
the live stream but i
i think i think this is probably good i
think this is probably good i think it's
time for me to maybe go get some
exercise
here's a complimentary comment uh from
someone i saw a bumper sticker that goes
don't worry about what other people
think they don't do it very often
exactly that summarizes uh one of the
key points i was trying to make
very very succinctly and then a question
on sleep
i'll take a stab at this tips resources
hacks for improving sleep
so i have written about sleep quite
extensively
in tools of titans i'll mention just a
few things
california poppy is very helpful for me
at least
with sleep and i do not want to take
melatonin on a daily basis i just
do not feel good about taking things
that consistently that affect
hormones without cycling off so i will
use melatonin occasionally although it
often leaves me feeling groggy there are
people who will take
say phosphatidylserine if your head
tends to
spin or remain very active when you're
trying to go to sleep there are some
people who will take
phosphatidylserine otherwise known as ps
which i did take say last night before
bed
to try to prevent the
or i should say lower the release of
cortisol which then can result in spikes
in
blood glucose so those are a couple of
supplemental interventions magnesium
l-3 and 8 is a version of magnesium that
is preferentially
absorbed in the brain that can also be
quite interesting but the greatest
determinant
of sleep quality or i should say
determinants
for me are a restricting caffeine intake
in time to before midnight
because the quarter life of caffeine
is about 12 hours which means if you
consume say 100 milligrams of caffeine
or 200 milligrams but let's go with 100
because it makes the math simple
a quarter of that will still be present
12 hours later so if you have
100 milligrams of caffeine that would be
one vibrant
at noon you'll still have 25 milligrams
of that caffeine in your system
roughly obviously we're dealing with
averages here at midnight
okay so so minimizing caffeine intake
and volume
and then also in time i think is a huge
i know
is a huge determinant of sleep quality
because i track my sleep quality with
something like
the aura ring i do wear the aura ring
o-u-r-a
which i find to be extremely helpful to
establish your baseline and then look at
what interventions actually
do to your sleep quality and types of
sleep
that is phases of sleep and
second is exercise and sun exposure so
when in doubt just get more exercise and
sun exposure
before lunch and without fail that will
increase my sleep quality in terms of
percentage of say restorative deep sleep
and also speed to sleep that is the
onset
of sleep and last is temperature
so one modification that i would make to
what i wrote in tools of titans
is i now use a
cover on my bed from eight sleep which
i find to be tremendously helpful for
both speed to sleep and quality
of sleep so temperature
is really one of the primary levers that
i like to pull
so i i sleep as cold as i can
without suffering and that solves
all sorts of relationship issues and
potential strife
around fighting over the thermostat also
so there are many
many benefits to using something
like the eight sleep bed cover which
which i do so those are a few
recommendations
that you could consider playing with but
you need to be able to
certainly evaluate whether or not your
interventions are working you could do
that subjectively
how you feel certainly but some metrics
will
be helpful and that is where something
like the aura ring
comes into play and can be combined with
a device
like eight sleep which also offers some
metrics
and markers on a nightly basis
and with all that said
there's a question here i'm going to
leave it as a cliffhanger there's a
question about how i learned
japanese through judo textbooks and so
on
confusingly the four-hour chef this book
that i wrote which was the hardest book
to put together
is in fact a book about
accelerated learning and it goes into
how i used
these textbooks and how i deconstructed
characters for
japanese in some length so i'll leave it
to people to explore the four hour chef
if they want to dig
more deeply into that and it talks about
accelerated learning not only for
factual knowledge or declarative
knowledge like memorizing characters and
foreign vocabulary and so on but also
procedural knowledge
skills shooting a basketball or
any thousands of other things knife
skills in the kitchen etc so all of
those things are deconstructed with a
framework
d-i-s-s-s and cafe
and those are two frameworks that you
can apply to learning
just about any skill i have not found
any exceptions
so with that thank you everyone for
joining it's been really fun to
connect with everybody on this live q a
i hope you found
some of it or any of it valuable
and i wish everyone a wonderful week
and a wonderful weekend and take care
and take care means not just take care
of other people but take care of
yourselves if your
cultivation of compassion does not
include yourself
then it is incomplete as my friend jack
cornfield would say
and until next time have fun be safe
and thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and
five bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things
i've found or that i've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that i've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the uh the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
butcherbox butcherbox makes it easy for
you to get high quality humanely raised
meat that you can trust
they deliver delicious 100 grass-fed
grass-finished beef
free-range organic chicken heritage
breed pork and wild caught seafood
directly to your door for me in the past
few weeks
i've cooked a ton of their salmon as
well as two delicious bbq rib racks
in the oven super simple they were the
most delicious pork ribs i've ever
prepared
my freezer is full of butcher box when
you become a member
you're joining a community focused on
doing what's better for all that means
caring about the lives of animals
the livelihoods of farmers treating our
planet with respect and enjoying
better meals together witcherbox
partners with folks small farmers
included who believe in going above and
beyond when it comes to caring for
animals the environment and
sustainability
and none of their meat is ever given
antibiotics or added hormones so how
does it work it's pretty simple
you choose your box and your delivery
frequency they offer
five boxes four curated box options as
well as the popular custom box so you
get exactly what you
and or your family love box options and
delivery frequencies can be customized
to fit your needs you can cancel at any
time
with no penalty butcherbox ships your
order frozen for freshness and packed in
an eco-friendly 100 recyclable box
it's easy it's fast it's convenient
i really really enjoy it and best of all
looking at the average cost it works out
to be less than six
dollars per meal bacon for life is back
right now new members can get bacon for
life that's right
when they sign up at butcherbox.com
tim that's one pack of free bacon in
every box for the life of your
subscription when you go to
butcherbox.com
tim this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn
it doesn't matter what your politics are
who you voted for everyone should have
the right to express themselves
freely one way to evade censorship is
with
expressvpn which i've been using since
the summer of 2019.
have you ever wondered how a lot of free
to access websites make all their money
well there are a bunch of ways but one
of them is by tracking your searches
video history everything you click on
and then building a profile
on you specifically and selling your
sensitive
data when you use the expressvpn app on
your computer or phone
you anonymize much of your online
presence by hiding your ip address that
makes your activity
more difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers
expressvpn encrypts 100 of your network
data to protect
you from eavesdroppers cybercriminals
and the like
you can protect all of your devices and
what i like most is how easy it is
to use it's easy to download easy to
install easy to set up it just takes
seconds practically that's why
expressvpn is rated
number one by cnet secure your internet
with the vpn i trust for online
protection
visit expressvpn.com
tim that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
tim to get three extra months free with
my exclusive link go to expressvpn.com
tim now to learn more
you